Speaker 1: Radical and repugnant. Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE suffered
another public humiliation. She seems to have a
very high tolerance for these as she is constantly
embarrassing and humiliating herself in public.
Fortunately, her constituents don't seem to care.
Let me tell you what happened. There was a hearing
about extremism, white supremacy, criminality, so
on and so forth. And one of the witnesses during
this hearing was a woman named Amy Spitz Melnick,
and she's a senior adviser on extremism at the
human rights organization Human Rights First.
Not only did Marjorie Taylor GREENE mispronounce
her her name, which we will get to in a moment,
but she seemed to once again lose a sense of how
time moves forward. And 2023 happened after 2024
and so on and so forth. And when the witness
tried to explain that every single politically
motivated murder in 2022 was committed by a
right wing extremist, Marjorie Taylor GREENE
brings up something that happened in 2023. And as
if GREENE is a five year old, it's explained to
her that it's a different year.
Speaker 2: Congresswoman,
when it comes to politically
motivated violence. In 2022,
every single murder was committed by a right
wing extremist. Every single murder in America
was committed by a right wing extremist or
politically motivated murder was committed
by a right wing extremist. Are you sure about
that? I am. Are you are you aware that the
Tennessee shooter just recently identified
as a man and she was a biological woman?
Was she a right wing extremist as well?
Speaker 4: And already time has expired.
Speaker 1: Allow the witness answer the question.
Speaker 2: So that was a shooting that happened
in 2023. There is no evidence as to
what ideology motivated that shooting.
Speaker 1: When there's a lot here, this is
this is actually it's it's another humiliation
for Marjorie Taylor. GREENE But there is a lot
here. First of all. Imagine that it were true
that all but one politically motivated shootings
were committed by right wingers. And imagine
that the shooting that Marjorie Taylor GREENE is
referring to had happened in 2022. It's actually
almost worse because the fact that Marjorie Taylor
GREENE would be able to say, well, there was this
one shooting that wasn't a right winger. It would
only reinforce that the politically motivated
shootings in the United States are almost
exclusively committed by right wingers. Now,
it happens that Marjorie Taylor GREENE brought up
a shooting that didn't happen in 2022. It happened
in 2023. So it just doesn't even make any sense.
But imagine that conversation. Every single one of
these was committed by by right wingers. Well,
other than this one. Oh, okay. All but one. So
it's still 99%. It's still not good. Now, it's
also true that even in the incident this year
with the trans shooter, we know the identity of
the individual as being trans. But as far as I've
seen, we actually don't know the motivations.
And just because you're trans doesn't mean that
the motivations were left wing motivations.
If they were, I will absolutely tell you it
wouldn't change the reality that overwhelmingly
politically motivated shootings in the United
States are committed by right wingers. So just
an embarrassment up and down the entire thing.
Here is the moment earlier during this where
Marjorie Taylor GREENE mispronounces the
witnesses name and then tries this hard
core questioning which just makes her
look like a horrible person that she is.
Speaker 2: This spit on neck. You were
talking about white supremacy, Helmick. Oh,
I apologize. The tall neck, Miss Bottleneck,
while you were talking about white supremacist
and abortion. I totally agree with you. There's
a lot of white supremacy supremacists in the
abortion movement and abortionists because they
have murdered over 20 million black babies
in America since Roe versus Wade in 1973.
That's on average, 900 black babies are aborted.
They're ripped apart inside their mother's womb.
Speaker 1: This is gag worthy
stuff from Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
Speaker 2: So I you know, I would agree with you
that that could be labeled white supremacy or we
can just label it murder and it should never be
happening. So if you want to talk about white
supremacy and the abortion movement, you should
really analyze that in your human rights groups
that you run as you collect donations from people
with your nonprofit. Because I think that is
something extremely important to talk about.
Speaker 1: Yeah, because Marjorie Taylor
GREENE doesn't grift for donations.
Speaker 2: Right. Is the right for those
black babies to have lives as American citizens,
the right for them to be born? The right for them
to be given a chance to live as free Americans
instead of murder? You think this is funny,
Miss Sputnik? Is this funny to you as babies
being murdered in the womb? Funny to you because
you're smirking and laughing.
Speaker 1: This is a very
tough Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
Speaker 2: I mean, right now what's
not funny are the black people and Hispanic people
and Jewish people and Muslim people who have been
murdered in synagogue, in church, in supermarkets,
in mosques, by white supremacists. Are you aware
that that all colored people are murdered? That is
that is a fact that every single color person has
been murdered, that that's not unusual.
Speaker 1: Pick a color. They've been
murdered, says Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
Speaker 2: Not just that people have.
Speaker 1: The question is, what are
the motivations for those murders,
which seems to be completely above
Marjorie Taylor Green's had her murdered.
Speaker 2: White people are
murder. To murder is not just
for minorities. That may be a shock to you.
Speaker 1: So a disgusting person, Marjorie
Taylor GREENE. And as usual, she's not good at
this. She will try to make these witnesses look
bad and she fails. That being said, the people who
like Marjorie Taylor GREENE see that and think,
wow, she did a really good job. She really
showed that witness. She really proved or wrong.
A common sense approach leads you to a different
conclusion. But a lot of this is what can I go
back to my constituents and justify what can I go
on HANNITY and claim that I did? But any thinking
person really a humiliation that Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is even a member of the United States House
of Representatives. That's really, you know, the
number one thing I hear from our foreign viewers
about Marjorie Taylor. GREENE it's not about
her specific views as deplorable as they are.
It's the disbelief that she could even get
elected in this country. How how how does
your country elect this person? And then you go
down to whatever, fourth, fourth or 14th district
of Georgia, wherever she represents, and you talk
to people and you go, oh, this is how this is how